foreign
s I'm the president and CEO of the
National Association of Manufacturers we
launched manufacturers for sensible
regulations because we you know we are
really excited about the fact that
Congress and the Biden Administration
has focused so much on growing the
manufacturing economy in the United
States
but even though that's a great
forward-looking agenda a lot of the
regulatory agencies are creating
impediments to allowing that to happen
so we want to call attention to the The
Barrage of regulations that
manufacturers are facing right now I can
give you a lot of examples of some of
the the
more concerning ones that we have I
think about the scope 3 regulations
coming out of the SEC or the ethylene
oxide regulation coming out of the EPA
there's just really a there's a ton of
regulations we we have a hundred
regulations out of 30 different agencies
that were actively engaged in at the Nam
we've never seen this level before in
any Administration so it's really the
volume and the number that are
challenging we've we've had we've had
reports from some manufacturers that
they've received 600 requests from
information from a regulator just
totaling 40 000 pages so it's this type
of a burden that puts a a chill on
investment we're not saying don't
regulate I think that's the most
important message here we know that
manufacturing has to be regulated it
should be regulated we want to be safe
we want to be we want to make sure that
the world is a healthier place and
there's no better place to do that than
in the United States
but sometimes we are seeing Regulatory
Agencies kind of reaching for the stars
and for something that may sound really
great in a press release but is simply
not achievable
the average cost now this is a
nine-year-old study I just want to point
that out so you can kind of deduce how
much more this cost burden is going to
be in 2023 and we are re-upping that
study but the average cost per for for
an employer per employee per year is
around ten thousand dollars for for
regulations that's every single employee
for manufacturers that number doubles
twenty thousand dollars per employee per
year but for a small manufacturer
somebody who's just doing everything
they can to make it and get by that cost
jumps to thirty five thousand dollars
per employee per year in Regulatory
Compliance costs that's before this
regulatory barrage this that's before
all the inflationary factors that came
into place over the last couple of years
so the the cost pressures on small
manufacturers are just extraordinary and
what we're seeing is we're seeing a lot
of small manufacturers say you know we
just can't do the this anymore we can't
make this particular product that is so
essential for the supply chain or in
some cases we see them say we're going
to just pack it up or even we're going
to let others in China or other
countries around the world make these
products because we simply can't do it
anymore
if you see other administrations within
the ones I've worked with are Bush 43
Obama Trump what you had was you had
somebody in the White House who was
always looking over the entire
hole of the federal government to say
our objective is to is to grow jobs grow
the economy grow manufacturing so let's
make sure that all the agencies are
talking to each other let's make sure
that from a centralized point
we are saying that this regulation can
can proceed as is this regulation may
not be achievable so let's make sure
that the timeline makes sense and this
regulation doesn't make any sense at all
and it's just going to Simply cause
people to close up shop or close up
their businesses if you had that kind of
coordination that would better help
to to bring the whole government
together on on the same for the same
objectives we we've asked the White
House to appoint this type of a
manufacturing quarterback if you will to
to look through all of the agency
proposals to make sure that that they're
all kind of in sync and they're not
they're not bumping against each other
or or counteracting each other or
causing undue burdens
a group of manufacturing associations
put together this letter to go to the
white house chief of staff to make sure
that the White House was was acutely
aware of not only our support for the
Biden agenda to grow Manufacturing in
the United States but our concern
that many of the agencies in the
president's own Administration are
holding back that progress are holding
back our ability to access the funds
that were were made available through
chips and Science and the inflation
reduction act and that letter was also
making a recommendation that we have a
quarterback to kind of oversee all of
the manufacturing priorities of the
administration and oversee the actions
of the agencies
130 Plus
Association signed that letter 49 out of
50. State manufacturing associations the
only one that didn't sign was Virginia
every other state wants to see some
action on regulatory relief so I think
this is a message that is coming across
loudly and clearly keep doing the good
things to advance manufacturing but make
sure that the entire government is
focused on the same agenda